today Ukraine's president zielinski
toured the eastern city of isium where
just weeks ago the place was occupied by
Russian forces in what was as much a
declaration of Victory as a show of
defiance zielinski today raised the
Ukrainian flag over the city
after seven months of the Russian
invasion Ukrainian forces have suddenly
reshaped some of the battle lines and
advance in the East and the south at
lightning speed forcing Russian troops
to retreat just as quickly and that is
sending shock waves all the way to
Moscow Russian President Vladimir Putin
is facing unprecedented criticism of his
War policy and there are calls for him
to ramp up the war effort including a
general draft but tonight Putin is
resisting insisting that Ukraine will
remain a limited operation we have more
now in this report
2015. in the city of izume President
zielinski shakes the hand of a Ukrainian
Commander
thanks to his troops hard work the city
has now been liberated from Russian
forces
but there's been so much fighting here
that there's not much of it left
[Music]
there are no surprises it's you know
that that's not shock for me
the view is very shocking but it's not
shock for me because we we began to see
the same
pictures from butcher from the first the
occupied territories so the same
destroyed buildings killed people
and so
what can I say Ukraine's Northeastern
counter-offensive has seen the Ukrainian
army take back a wide swathe of
territory in a space of just a few days
but residents here are shell-shocked
what they endured during six months of
Russian occupation is just starting to
come to light
in the battle scarred city of balaclia
southeast of khakive reports of torture
are emerging
they made me hold two wires attached to
an electric generator the faster you
spin the higher the voltage
they kept spinning it and asking
questions
they said I was lying so they did it
more
it happened to some prisoners every
other day
with the Ukrainian Army back in control
residents here long to put the dark days
of War behind them
and see the Ukrainian flag rise over the
country once again
well my first guest tonight is a
zielinski Insider from June 2019 to June
2021 Yulia Mendel served as the
spokesperson for Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski it would be the
crucial foundation for her new book
published this week which is entitled
the fight of Our Lives my time with
zelinski Ukraine's battle for democracy
and what it means for the world
Julia Mendo joins me tonight from New
York City Julie it's good to have you
with us this evening that the pictures
that we saw today the flag going up over
territory that had been controlled by
the Russians just days ago that flag
being hoisted by zielinski
um how did you feel when you saw those
images
well thank you first for having me so
crane is regaining
and it's really a fascinating
development that all the country has
been waiting for the last seven months
it's like seven months of the battle of
the fight for our very existence and now
when we see and when we have shown to
the world that we can regain the
territories back we hope that the
community International Community will
stay unified and will hope uh will
provide us all the opportunities and
resources to fight Russia out of the
territory of Ukraine you know that one
and a two million of ukrainians still
stay in occupation under Russia and also
Ukraine uh is moving not only in the
northern East and east of the country
but also trying to move to the herself
region which is my hometown region which
is in the South and the country and this
also brings joy to my uh to me that you
know I feel like my own hometown can be
liberated very soon and let me ask you
this rapid Ukrainian advance that we
have seen it it apparently called the
the Russians by surprise were you
surprised at how quickly events unfolded
and how you know this this course of
history began turning
military expert to be surprised but I've
heard so many
uh uh fascinated
descriptions of what is uh going on on
the
um Battleground from a very matured
military people from generals around the
world and we all understood that
Ukrainian Army is capable of winning
this war because we understand that our
people uh have a very determined and
very devoted they have what to fight for
contrary to Russian army our motivation
is to retake our territory and to stand
independent country we are fighting here
for the values and we are fighting for
the Democratic uh way of life we have
chosen that instead of Russians and if
we look at the Russians first of all uh
the corruption became uh the part of
Russian identity and that's why the Army
came in Ukraine and very soon they
didn't have food and fuel and they
didn't have what to and how to fight
with and the second is they don't have
any motivation just to come and kill
people here in Ukraine I wanted to talk
a little bit about your story I want you
to if you could to take us back to June
of 2019 that's when you joined what was
then this new Vladimir zielinski
administer Administration how radical of
a departure was that Administration to
the ones that Ukraine had seen
previously
definitely was a big shot uh let me say
that well de merzelanski was an absolute
navis to Ukrainian politics I'm
describing a lot of details in my new
book the fight of Our Lives I'm
describing how this person from an
entertainment business comes to politics
and changes it forever but um before
that when two old school politicians
wanted to run elections for the
president of Ukraine I saw that
ukrainians had such a fatigue they were
so irritated by this old school manner
of behavior president zielinski will do
muslinski gave a lot of Hope people
really saw him as an equal one as a
person from the people and they wanted
him to change Ukrainian politics he won
73 percent this is the record let me
remind you that and he's done amazing
reforms up to now and stands as a
military leader yeah I mean he had a a
strong mandate when he came into office
and how do you explain this I mean we've
got a man who made his career as a
comedian who has morphed into this
incredibly effective commander-in-chief
into this respected wartime president
let me say that comedian was of course
one of his most popular roles everybody
saw him on the stage and he was really
hilarious and he was really very
talented comedian on the other hand what
was not seen what was behind the stage
is that he is a lawyer by education and
that he has built a huge Empire of humor
a huge business in post office space it
is a big challenge so there he actually
developed as a leader while seeing all
these challenges in early 2000s he even
stood against moscow's pressure towards
his own career and actually decided to
not to continue in Moscow but to build
this big business in Ukraine I'm sure
that this is where he his character as a
leader developed and grew and to be
frank I was there for 25 months and I
was traveling with him to donbass that
Russia had invaded back in 2014. the
military actions had been lasting for
eight years years and I saw him going to
the front lines just to handshake with
the soldiers and even going there when
the shelling was renewed to show that
the leader does not run away so uh I was
not surprised that he stayed with
Ukrainian people when there was threat
to his life and to his family and
actually when Russia was approaching to
Keith who would you say is more
responsible for this incredibly
strong sense of Ukrainian identity that
we see on display today has it been
president zielinski or has it been
Russian President Vladimir Putin
foreign
question I'm not sure
it is the one I can respond but
Ukrainian identity has been always
different from Russia you know even in
1812 you can read some notes from
Russian generals who were traveling on
the territory of Ukraine and that still
was the Russian Empire what was called
but at the same time in this note it is
written that people see that the life
there is different people are different
foods is different languages different
houses are different identity was
different Ukraine considers that we've
been fighting Russia for the last 400
years but the fight for democracy for
the values the fight for independence of
really Ukraine as an equal and strong
country is happening right now well I'm
sure there are lots of people around the
world who hope the best for you and
Ukraine and hope that this fight for
Freedom you know ends sooner rather than
later Julia Mendel author of the fight
of Our Lives my time with zelinski we
appreciate your time please come back
and talk with us again thank you
thank you for having me